welcome back to CBS this morning as you
can see we are coming to you from our
homes so we can practice safe social
distancing during the corona virus
outbreak but still bring you the news
you need to know and the news today not
good for yet another day the US has more
than two hundred and sixteen thousand
reported cases of this virus overall and
the death toll rose by more than a
thousand yesterday alone now topping 50
100 the mayor of Los Angeles is urging
the city's four million residents to
cover their faces if they leave their
homes now that goes beyond state and
national guidelines but Mayor Eric
Garcetti said people should not wear the
medical-grade mask needed by health care
workers so Gail it seems like the deeper
we get into this crisis the more the
guidance on the face mask seems to
evolve yes yes you're so right I'm now
even rethinking wearing a mask but the
most important thing is that the nurses
and the doctors who need it get it and
that's what we're talking about Tony the
nurses at 15 hospitals and seven states
they're protesting this week over what
they call a lack of preparedness by a
major US hospital chain they say the
shortage of protective equipment is
putting them and their families and
patients at risk senior investigative
correspondent that's Catherine Herridge
has their stories what I can tell you is
um it has quickly grown into a war zone
ICU nurse Diane Kay shot this video
inside her Yonkers New York Hospital
because she says she's so concerned this
is the paint of coveralls the lack of
personal protective gear is putting her
and her fellow nurses at risk no
isolation gowns and we are riddled with
fear and anxiety because we don't have
the proper equipment to take care of
these patients
so what we're expendable that's how we
feel CBS News spoke to more than a dozen
nurses in six states who said their
hospitals or nursing homes are rationing
critical supplies it's now routine to
reuse gowns and masks it's not made to
be used multiple times
Shelley Hughes works at a long-term care
facility in Washington State her husband
found a box of n95 masks in their home
emergency kit everyone I gave one to a
young lady that I work with my fear is
that since the measures and in response
from this day has not at all matched the
need or the crisis I'm afraid that I'll
see my co-workers dying New York City
ICU nurse tre Quan came back from
maternity leave last month I was really
torn about returning because I was
worried about leaving my baby and
breastfeeding and also just bringing
back you know the virus but I I couldn't
stay home and kind of watch
she returned too overwhelmed emergency
rooms in colleagues with coronavirus
symptoms the units and nurses are
getting sick we are in the ICUs now as
patients but going public about their
concerns also has risks asked what is at
stake during our interview diane case
said my job and quite possibly being
brandon there's a real big line here and
doctors don't face the same retribution
that nurses do they are also deeply
conflicted the guilt toward not tending
to patients right now outweighs the
guilt toward my family no health care
worker deserves to martyr themselves to
this broken system i can't kiss my
children i can't hug my children and
this is gonna go on for months we work
hard for our patients because we're
impassioned about what we do but we
didn't sign up to be exposed to a killer
virus without proper protection since
our interview shelly hughes who gave one
of her n95 masks to a pregnant colleague
has begun self isolating hughes has some
symptoms and she doesn't know whether
it's her asthma acting up or koba 19
gail Catherine I'm so glad they're
speaking up without them speaking up
changes will not happen thank you so
much